nice to see everyone's just sitting here
patiently with their two eggs two
sausages pancake and i'm gonna say rice
grits cottage cheese my point is why is
no one eating yet rick and morty episode
sub standard breakfast operating
procedure cliche this time it's the case
of the inappropriate bowl of cereal
everyone knows that you eat cereal while
the main breakfast is cooking and if
that [ __ ] has been sitting there in a
puddle of milk getting soggier by the
second i will lose my damn mind and
don't think it gets a pass if this
morning malady is at the pre-milked part
of its journey this bowl is filled to
capacity with cereal how does morty
expect to be able to add any milk to
this without some serious cereal seepage
what is up with this balloon game that
jerry's playing first i thought he was
popping just the blue balloons but then
he pops a red one and then i wondered
why there's no score listed so what's
the point but then i realized their apps
where you just pop fake bubble wrap like
this so now the sins for app culture and
bleeding my bank account dry 99 cents at
a time sorry i wasn't paying attention
to a conversation about vampires in
fairness to jerry vampires are one of
the least interesting conversation
topics to happen around this breakfast
table so not sure why everyone's so
worked up about it also making me use
the phrase in fairness to jerry we tried
a couple's therapist that's earth
therapy you might as well ask a horse to
fix a merry-go-round it may not be
perfect and may take a lot of work but
strangely enough earth therapy is the
only therapy most people on earth have
access to and if i have to throw sin on
one of the funniest shows of all time
just to remind you that therapy is
indeed amazing ding away also does he
mean an actual horse or one of the
horses on the merry-go-round itself i
suppose one is as ridiculous as the
other but both prove the point he's
trying to make but this is an oddly
specific example of futility and
sometimes i just want to know where this
comes from i'm gonna go make some wooden
stakes good luck summer there's one
thing i know about rick and morty it's
they don't really specialize in having
steaks i booked you for a two-day
intensive at nuptia 4 the galaxy's most
successful couples counseling institute
this place has a 100 success rate of
fixing marriages and is open to the
entire galaxy but somehow rick was able
to book them in with zero notice i can't
even book a damn haircut with that sort
of notice my shoe fits up your ass you
wish
[Laughter]
take that back you do not think that
about me show doesn't clearly explain
that she's not really angry about the
whole killer insect thing it was
actually the four boobs who wants to
carry around two more of those nuisances
character closes a door and is scared by
a younger [ __ ] clone of their
grandfather standing behind it cliche oh
my god toby matthews boy crazy summer is
my least favorite summer but strangely
enough also my most favorite summer the
next step is to watch your mythologues
interact together and uh big surprise
it's never pretty is a battle between
the physical manifestations of your
deepest and most uncensored thoughts
about your significant other really the
sort of thing that should be aired in
front of complete strangers in what way
is that therapeutic for anybody
we can work together
smearing your arm oil on your worm
husband honestly guys have you ever
tried to send this show modesty hands
and i guess it's time for me to get back
inside the old timer i'll let one of our
honorary tv sense team members take this
one um phrasing where are the smith
mythologues sending someone into check
instead of just watching back the
surveillance footage you do have
surveillance footage in your fancy
futuristic marriage monster prisons
right also this works seriously was the
wall matching color of this giant
[ __ ] glute ball really enough to hide
it i mean it's clearly spilling over
these steps what the heck did glitc glac
fufeme think this thing was is anybody
listening can anyone understand stop
looking at me like that and actually
help me rhyming understand with help me
surely race this advanced has the
ability to present these murderous
marital monstrosities as harmless
holograms they'd still be able to
observe how they interact without the
risk of all this maiming then again i
suppose that means this b plot would
actually end up being about the
complexities of dealing with long-term
relationships and then we'd be in danger
of actually learning something [ __ ] that
noise continue the smashing and slicing
also if they absolutely have to take a
physical form which they don't why would
they send this guy all on his own and
leave the door wide [ __ ] open if you
know that this is the sort of havoc and
destruction they could cause and this
place has a 100 success rate my trip
advisor review shall say otherwise what
the hell kind of relationship do you
have i mean you just screamed they're
codependent
so are you being rhetorical here has
your universally lauded marriage
counseling service never dealt with
codependency earlier these creatures
called our planet earth as if they
didn't know how to pronounce earth but
the entire map is in english make up
your mind ridiculous animated comedy
show if you can find one too we should
be safe for hours maybe days there is so
much room in this panel for both of them
that even jack and rose are scoffing at
jerry right now get outside read a book
reading
rick this episode says tiny rick more
than the pickle rick episode says pickle
rick i feel like the writers may be
overcompensating for something here hmm
tiny
pickle
give me a second i'm gonna figure it out
why was knight raider called knight
rider the car's name was kit nobody rode
michael knight rick would be excellent
at a night writer episode of tv sins why
was knight raider called knight rider
the car's name was kit nobody rode
michael knight see get your [ __ ]
together get it all together and put it
in a backpack all your sh this gets it
together for some
no nobody's doing that around 41 percent
of people are doing that you want jerry
i don't even want jerry that's jerryist
stacking your cups this eye is just
asking for some [ __ ] kid to
accidentally knock them over as a
distraction to put some special
ingredient in the punch bowl shorter cup
stacks are the road to true sobriety
friends let me out let me out
this is not a dance this sin goes out to
the rick and morty fan who rocked this
dance at his local club thinking
everyone would think it was hilarious
for getting the rick and morty uber fans
are a much smaller subset of humanity
than you might think and was mocked and
embarrassed and could never show his
face again in allen's anticipation
station and it's me this sid goes out to
me you're a great student the fact that
you're an 80 year old man in the clone
body it never bothered me but it really
should why is everyone even aware of
this let alone okay with it and how has
rick managed to prove himself as a great
student he's only been there since this
morning and i don't think he's even been
in any classes and if he has
why he's meant to be hunting [ __ ]
vampires how can one sentence contain so
much sin
summer smith is a [ __ ] psycho nerd
and she just got me kicked out of school
not owning your sh i'm here to save you
or my name isn't jerry smith
yes jerry smith
yeah no show has the right to be this
funny and genuinely insightful at the
same time it's just not fair to the
other shows and yes that means i'm
giving this show a sin because other
shows can't match it but don't look at
me that way you knew which channel you
clicked on honey i like to believe that
hugh jackman's character from the
prestige survived found some youth juice
and eventually became his character and
reminiscence and that this machine is
the twisted result of a merger of both
of his infamous inventions i have
nothing to base this on but now that
i've shared this with you don't act like
you don't want it to be true as well
unless this clock is broken and there's
no reason to assume it is the school
dance was taking place at two in the
afternoon when they should all no i
don't know be in classes also this
calendar has at most 20 squares in total
of course this all could be taking place
in an alternate reality where the months
only have 20 days and school dances
regularly take place at 2pm but i'm not
prepared to believe in a universe where
such madness is possible now back to the
80 year old and the clone body of his
teenage self attempting to murder his
original older self what are you gonna
do i'm tiny rick i'm the coolest kid in
your school you have been expelled sir
your threats are hollow rick comes out
of the vat and marty says rick while
summer says pants and while i don't
blame summer for her cultural norm views
on nude body boundaries regarding
grandparents i will say it's weird that
you chose this moment to be all the
sudden so grossed out when his tiny rick
has been in clear view the whole episode
why go through all of the effort of
strategically covering the rick if
you're just gonna blur it anyway now is
there a set budget of blurs per episode
mass sanchezide just so you're prepared
there's a bunch of dead me's in the
garage speaking of multiple me's what
the [ __ ] is going to happen to the
assorted cast of into the jerry verse
back here i know nobody behind rick and
morty is interested in answering those
sort of questions but damn it i want my
loose ends tied up hey phrasing
i hate you i hate you more
it ain't worth people i beat china i
think it's okay to dream morty i'm gonna
go make some wooden stakes
[Music]
what's that
a very unpleasant little creature what's
his problem he's got a
hunting a vampire with my grandkids now
this is not going to be pretty we're
talking violence strong language adult
contest
surprise motherfu
all right everybody this next one's
coming straight from the heart making
the lyrics up right off the top of my
head
let me out what you see is not the same
person as me my life's a lie i'm not
my children may feast on modern flesh my
home planet is far away and long since
gone